The all-powerful pharaohs of ancient Egypt
were frequently buried alongside a literal
wealth of fabulous treasure- treasure that,
as you can probably imagine, the pharaohs
were very keen to protect.
So did they actually have significant preventative
measures in place to stop anyone from stealing
their stuff after they’d gone a little moldy?
Well, yes and no, but when it comes to the
idea of elaborate booby traps or puzzles as
depicted by Hollywood and in games, definitively
no.
To begin with, it’s important to understand
that generally the pharaoh’s own subjects
and in some cases, their direct successors,
were the ones stealing their afterlife retirement
plan.
You see, a pharaoh’s power was more or less
absolute and they could do pretty much anything
they pleased.
As a result, many pharaohs would have the
tombs of their ancestors looted, in some cases
even reusing the items for their own burial.
There are even stories of pharaohs unceremoniously
having the mummy of their predecessor dumped
out of their sarcophagus so that even that
container could be reused.
This all was particularly the case in times
of hardship when Egyptian nobility would think
nothing of ransacking the final resting place
of a beloved family member or ancestor because,
well, technically, in their view it was their
stuff sitting there.
A perk of being the ones who set the rules,
this tomb raiding practise by nobility was
tolerated in the ancient Egyptian world.
However, tomb raiding from individuals not
directly related to the deceased wasn’t
as much and it carried some rather harsh penalties.
Punishments for raiding a tomb ranged from
brutal death to public flogging, depending
on how important the crypt that was desecrated
was and the value of the items stolen.
In regards to the kind of death penalty meted
out to thieves, it was common practise to
burn them alive.
Why?
Well in addition to being a rather unpleasant
way to die, this would condemn the thief to
an eternity of nothingness due to the belief
in ancient times that if you died without
a body, you couldn’t enter the afterlife.
Other forms of execution included decapitation,
which would similarly mean the thief couldn’t
enter the afterlife, or impalement, which
the ancient Egyptians believed would result
in the spirit of the deceased being tied to
that singular location, forever…
Obviously, this was seen as a bad thing and
the hope of pharaohs was that such harsh punishments
would deter thieves.
The problem with all these punishments is
that it would seem it was rather easy to get
out of getting into any trouble at all.
For example, consider this account by one
11th century BCE tomb raider, Amenpanufer,
on both his method of tomb raiding and how
he got out of trouble, even when caught:
We went to rob the tombs as is our usual habit
and we found the pyramid tomb of King Sobekemsaf,
this tomb being unlike the pyramids and tombs
of the nobles which we usually rob.
We took our copper tools and forced a way
into the pyramid of this king through its
innermost part.
We located the underground chambers and, taking
lighted candles in our hands, went down.
We found the god lying at the back of his
burial place.
And we found the burial place of Queen Nubkhaas,
his consort, beside him, it being protected
and guarded by plaster and covered with rubble.
We opened their sarcophagi and their coffins,
and found the noble mummy of the king equipped
with a sword.
There were a large number of amulets and jewels
of gold on his neck and he wore a headpiece
of gold.
The noble mummy of the king was completely
covered in gold and his coffins were decorated
with gold and with silver inside and out and
inlaid with precious stones.
We collected the gold that we found on the
mummy of the god including the amulets and
jewels which were on his neck.
We set fire to their coffins.
After some days, the district officers of
Thebes heard that we had been robbing in the
west and they arrested me and imprisoned me
in the office of the mayor of Thebes.
I took the twenty deben of gold that represented
my share and I gave them to Khaemope, the
district scribe of the landing quay of Thebes.
He released me and I rejoined my colleagues
and they compensated me with a share again.
And so I got into the habit of robbing the
tombs.
Tomb raiding was so commonplace in ancient
times that near enough every level of society
took part in it, including somewhat hilariously,
the very people charged with constructing
the tombs, as well as those in charge of burying
the dead.
Sadly, while Hollywood would have you believe
that the tombs of ancient pharaohs were teeming
with a manner of deadly booby-traps, the truth
is much more vanilla.
For starters, the idea of elaborate booby-traps
in ancient tombs is considered to be nothing
more than a myth.
To quote one Emily Teeter, an expert on Egyptian
and Nubian antiquities working at the University
of Chicago –
I am really sorry to report that if curses
are out, then there is really nothing devious.
Hollywood has turned standard architectural
features like sliding portcullis blocks, shafts,
and sand filled chambers into objects of horror.
This isn’t to say you won’t find many
reports of booby-traps from otherwise seemingly
reputable sources, stating things like that
Egyptian tombs were filled with everything
from razor sharp wires located at exactly
head height to deadly snakes- all of which
have been written off by actual experts as
fanciful claims that have no basis in reality.
Instead, the countermeasures in place to deter
thieves tended to just be obstacles put in
the path to the goods, such as huge slabs
of granite or random debris and the like blocking
the way.
They also sometimes employed empty chambers
with the real chamber containing the various
goods walled up somewhere else in the structure,
etc.
Other than these sorts of rather quaint security
measures, other deterrents tended to just
be more metaphysical in nature- mostly limited
to curses that would condemn a thieves’
soul to a eternity of perpetual agony or the
like.
For example, consider the following curse
placed over the tomb of pharaoh Amenhotep
by one of his high priests which threatened,
amongst other things, that any thief would
–
lose their earthly positions and honors, be
incinerated in a furnace in execration rites,
capsize and drown at sea, have no successors,
receive no tomb or funerary offerings of their
own, and their bodies would decay because
they will starve without sustenance and their
bones will perish…
Given the widespread pilfering of tombs that
went on back then and the fact that the person
placing the curse would sometimes take part
in said pilfering, it’s safe to say these
sorts of curses weren’t something a lot
of people took seriously.
Pharaoh Amenhotep got so annoyed with how
often the tombs of his ancestors were raided
that he ordered the construction of a place
known as Set-Ma’at – quite literally “Place
of Truth” – a village of conscripts charged
with both building and protecting the tombs
of nobility.
The idea of Set-Ma’at, sometimes also known
as Deir el-Medina was simple –
The workers of the village would create the
tombs and protect their creation and, since
they relied on the sta
te for their wages and homes, they would be
loyal and discreet regarding the location
of the tombs and the amount of treasure to
be found within.
However, frequent delays in the delivery of
supplies to the villagers, including things
like food and water, and the basic nature
of said payment, did little to foster trust
and loyalty amongst the townsfolk, which,
coupled with their intricate knowledge of
the tombs themselves and exactly what treasure
was stored within them and where, naturally
led to widespread theft.
Despite the isolated nature of the village,
workers could still fence stolen goods by
simply walking to a nearby city and trading
the goods, often to those who would then do
things like melt down any gold or the like
and create new objects that couldn’t be
traced back to a tomb.
Now all this said, it has been speculated
that hematite powder, which when inhaled in
sufficient quantities could potentially cause
death, was used as something of a booby trap,
if not terribly effective.
For example, in one tomb discovered in 2001
at the Bahariya Oasis, there was several inches
of this powder on the floor.
It’s also sometimes said that mercury was
used as an intentional deterrent in many ancient
tombs that have been discovered in China,
like the burial site of Emperor Qin Shi Huang.
However, this notion is universally dismissed
by experts, though the sheer amount of mercury
sometimes used was such that it could still
be a potential health hazard, if also likely
not terribly effective at accidentally preventing
tomb raiding.
For the most part though, the tombs of the
ancient emperors, kings and pharaohs were
protected, if at all, merely by simple physical
barriers, abstract threats such as curses,
and the ever present risk of being horribly
mutilated and killed should the perpetrator
ever be caught, assuming they didn’t simply
just bribe their way out of the situation.
Unsurprisingly from this, the plundering of
tombs was widespread and almost comically
easy for certain subsets of the population
who had access to the tombs
or the right tools.